E
MEDIA, JOE BIDEN HAS SUDDENLY
BECOME MUM ON HIS DOCUMENT
SCANDAL BUT OUR QUESTION TONIGHT
ON THE ANGLE IS HOW MUCH LONGER
CAN HE AVOID ANSWERING
QUESTIONS?
AND IS HE PUTTING OFF HIS 2024
ANNOUNCEMENT, JOINING US IS
CHARLIE KIRK, AND ARI FLEISHER.
ARI, YOU'VE BEEN IN THE CALDRON
IN THE WHITE HOUSE WHEN THE
PRESS WANTS ANSWER.
DID IT SEEM LIKE BIDEN FELT
COMFORTABLE IN THAT SITUATION?
HE KIND OF GAVE THAT ODD SMILE.
WHAT WAS GOING DWLU
THROUGH YD
WHEN YOU SAW THAT?
>> ONE IS YOU DON'T TALK BECAUSE
IT'S POLITICAL, BECAUSE THERE IS
SOMETHING MILITARY GOING ON SO
YOU JUST DON'T WANT TO TALK.
THE OTHER, THOUGH, IS YOU ARE
ORDERED BY YOUR LAWYERS OR
YOU'RE TOLD BY YOUR LAWYERS IF
YOU TALK YOU COULD BE SUPPOSING
YOURSELF TO CRIMINAL LIABILITY.
ANYBODY YOU TALK TO COULD BECOME
A WITNESS.
THE INDEPENDENT COUNSEL, SPECIAL
COUNSEL CAN CALL AND ASK WHAT
DID JOE BIDEN SAY TO YOU?
THAT APPLIES TO THE WHITE HOUSE
STAFF.
EVERY TIME THE WHITE HOUSE
SECRETARY TALKS TO THE WHITE
HOUSE COUNSEL SHE COULD GET
QUESTIONED BY THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
SO THAT'S WHY THEY CLAM UP, BUT
THE PRESS SHOULD NOT LET THEM
GET AWAY WITH IT.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS TO DO.
BUT THERE ARE WAYS THE PRESS CAN
BANG AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
ESPECIALLY THE PRESIDENT, TO TRY
TO GET MORE ANSWERS.
>> LAURA: CHARLIE, IT SEEMED
LIKE BIDEN WAS POISED TO
ANNOUNCE HIS 2024 RE-ELECTION
BID EARLY IN THE NEW YEAR.
IS THIS KIND OF DELAYING ALL OF
THAT?
CAN HE DELAY IT LONG INTO THE
NEW YEAR?
>> OH, I THINK, IN FACT, I THINK
PART OF THE REASON A LOT OF THIS
IS COMING OUT RIGHT NOW IS
BECAUSE EVERYBODY FELT FAIRLY
CERTAIN HE WAS GOING TO ANNOUNCE
IN SHORT ORDER, AND I THINK, YOU
KNOW, LOOK, IF YOU JUST STEP
BACK AND YOU LOOK AT WHAT WE NOW
KNOW THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DID DURING THE 2020 CAMPAIGN, TO
COVER PROBLEMS FOR JOE BIDEN,
AND TO HELP GET HIM ELECTED, AND
WHAT THE PRESS OBVIOUSLY DID TO
COVER FOR JOE BIDEN, THEY ARE
NOT DOING THAT ANYMORE.
TO ME, THAT'S THE BIGGEST
TAKEAWAY FROM ALL OF THIS.
THE PRESS AND THE DOJ HAVE BOTH,
AT SOME LEVEL, TURNED ON JOE
BIDEN, AND JOE BIDEN CAN'T WIN
ANYTHING UNLESS HE'S GOT THE DOJ
AND THE PRESS WORKING FOR HIM.
>> LAURA: WELL, ARI, THIS GOES
TO YOUR EXPERTISE IN THIS
MATTER.
THE PRESS REALLY DID PROTECT
BIDEN ALL THROUGH THE 2020
CAMPAIGN.
THEY ALLOWED HIM TO DO THAT
HOLOGRAM CAMPAIGN WHERE HE NEVER
REALLY HAD TO APPEAR, NEVER HAD
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THAT'S TURNED.
>> IT FAILED AFTER THE
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN AND
THEN THEY WENT EASY ON BIDEN
AGAIN.
BUT IF I WAS THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS CORPS, HERE'S WHAT I WOULD
DO.
INSTEAD OF ASKING QUESTIONS YOU
KNOW THEY WON'T ANSWER, ASK THE
SECRETARY, WHEN YOU SAID THE
SEARCH WAS COMPLETE AND IT
WASN'T, WHO TOLD YOU THAT?
WAS THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL?
ASK THE PRESS SECRETARY, HAVE
YOU BEEN IN TOUCH WITH JOE
BIDEN'S PERSONAL ATTORNEY?
IS THAT WHERE YOU GET YOUR
INFORMATION FROM?
YOU CAN UNRAVEL A LOT ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE PROCESS
THAT WOULD ASK PROCESS QUESTIONS
THAT SHE SHOULD ANSWER.
THE SAME WITH THE REST OF THE
WHITE HOUSE STAFF.
THESE ARE THINGS THE PRESS CORPS
SHOULD BE DIGGING INTO, AND IT'S
GOING TO EXPOSE HOW THE WHITE
HOUSE BLUNDERED SO BADLY, WHEN
IT WAS FOUND A FOURTH TIME,
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS FOUND.
THIS IS SERIOUS, LAURA, BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T HAVE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS OUTSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> LAURA: WELL, CHARLIE, I MEAN,
WE JOKED LAST WEDNESDAY OR
THURSDAY BEFORE WE LEARNED ABOUT
THE OTHER DOCUMENT, THE
DOCUMENTS WOULD BE IN THE DOG
BED, YOU COULD FIND THEM LATER
ON BUT LITTLE DID WE KNOW THE
DRIP-DRIP-DRIP WAS REAL.
I DON'T THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE CONFIDENT THAT THERE AREN'T
MORE DOCUMENTS OUT THERE.
THERE IS NO REASON FOR US TO
BELIEVE THAT THERE AREN'T, NOT
AT THIS JUNCTURE.
>>, NO I THINK PROBABLY THE
PRESUMPTION SHOULD BE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR ABOUT MORE.
THAT THERE ARE MORE DOCUMENTS
OUT THERE.
LOOK, THE BOTTOM LINE IS, JOE
BIDEN STOLE THESE DOCUMENTS FROM
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
THEY HAVE BEEN, WE DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY HAVE BEEN FOR SIX
YEARS BUT FOR SOME REASON, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ALLOWED
HIS LAWYERS TO GO IN AND PROCESS
THE CRIME SCENE.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE NEED TO GET
THE ANSWERS TO A